a surprise party might be fun but a
surprise on your cloud bill usually
isn't thankfully you can set up budgets
and alerts using Google cloud platform
to closely monitor your costs and work
with the appropriate teams so that they
can take action if needed on this
episode of beyond your bill we'll talk
about setting up budgets and how you can
get notified when anything unexpected
happens
[Music]
setting a budget in GCP lets you trigger
notifications when your costs hit or are
forecasted to hit a specified amount you
can set up a budget for an entire
billing account or multiple budgets for
different combinations of projects and
GCP products so that you can stay
informed on the areas that matter most
to you let's look at the interface where
you can manage your budgets set one up
and see what the options for
notifications are we'll start by going
to the budgets and alerts page in the
GCB console you can use the top left
navigation to choose billing and then
select the billing account from there
click on budgets and alerts only billing
account administrators are able to
create or update budgets and alerts for
billing account so make sure that you
have the right permissions for the
billing account that you've chosen on
this page you can see all the budgets
that belong to this billing account each
budget is made up of a few different
important pieces first you have the name
for the budget which is helpful for you
to identify what this budget is meant to
track next is the budget type which can
either be specified amount where you set
a fixed amount to compare your monthly
spend to or last month spent where you
target an amount based on the previous
month spent we'll come back to those
when you walk through creating a budget
after that is the scope of the budget
which is the combinations of projects
and GCP products that this budget covers
so you may have a budget for your entire
billing account one for just your
production projects one for just your
big query spend or multiple for any
combination of those on the other side
of the budget are the actual threshold
details for when the budget should send
out an alert notification each budget
can have multiple thresholds and you can
see an overview of the current status
for each budget on this page the
thresholds are percentages of either the
amount you entered or the last month
spent based on the type of budget you
can always come to this page to see your
budgets and click on one to edit it
let's go through and create a budget to
see all the options we'll do that by
clicking on the create budget button at
the top the first screen is the scope of
the budget which includes the name
projects and products covered if you
don't choose any projects or products
from the drop-down this budget will
default to the entire billing account
since you can set up as many budgets as
you want feel free to create multiple
budgets to track different groups of
projects and products based on your
needs on the next screen you can choose
the type of budget if you choose
specified
you can choose a target amount for this
budget to track towards depending on the
cost you're trying to measure
that could be a hundred dollars a
hundred thousand dollars or more if you
choose last month's spend the amount
will be pre-populated with this been
from last month based on the scope you
just chose and it'll be updated every
month for example if you choose a
product that you haven't used before or
you've only used within the free tier
this amount may show up as zero this can
be a good way to get notified as soon as
you start to spend money on something
you didn't expect to spend it on in
addition you can choose to include
credits in the budget amount including
credits means you'll take the total cost
and then subtract any credits that were
applied for that billing period credits
may include things like usage discounts
promotions or grants on the next step
you'll be able to set up the actions you
can set up different thresholds based on
the amount from the previous step for
when the alert notification should
trigger for example you may want to set
an alert for when you've reached 50% 90
percent and 100 percent of your budget
for the month you can also add
additional thresholds in case you want
more granularity and each fish hold can
be based on actual or forecasted costs
actual cost thresholds trigger when the
spend from the scope that you selected
exceeds the specified amount for example
you could setup a 50% actual cost
threshold on a thousand dollar budget
and you'll get an alert notification
when your cost exceeds $500 forecasted
cost thresholds trigger when your cost
is predicted to exceed the threshold
amount by the end of the month if you
add a forecasted cost threshold for a
hundred ten percent on a thousand dollar
budget it'll trigger an alert
notification as soon as your cost for
the total billing period is expected to
hit $1100 even if you're only a few days
into the month there's also an option
for connecting budget to pub/sub for
programmatic budget notifications which
let you add more advanced cost controls
to your budgets we'll talk about that in
a later video but you can check out the
link below for more information keep in
mind that different GCP products or
services update costs at different times
most services will update cost within an
hour but some may take up to a full day
to update each service has costs based
on different metrics as well we
recommend setting multiple budgets so
that you can get alerted as soon as
possible and take action once you save
your budget you're good to go so it may
take a
two hours before it kicks in here's an
email alert that was sent out for a
budget that was set to a hundred percent
for a ten dollar budget we can see the
display name of the budget the budget
amount and period the triggering
threshold and the Associated billing
account ID in the email it's also easy
to get straight to the budget page in
case you want to see more information or
edit your budgets only billing account
administrators and billing account users
will get an email notification for a
budget alert remember budget alerts are
sent out based on the rules you set but
they don't actually stop any usage from
happening if you want to go beyond
emails and automate actions usually
consider using quotas or programmatic
budget notifications both of which we'll
talk about in future videos check out
the links below for more information
about setting up budgets and alerts
[Music]
[Music]